gary gensler a few weeks ago compared
regulation in the cryptocurrency market
to
regulation in cars when we finally had
cars get regulated we had stop signs we
had uh crosswalks and traffic lights uh
car adoption skyrocketed do you think
the same thing is true or will be true
for cryptocurrency i think you basically
just said that essentially once you get
more regulation you'll be able to do a
lot more with it are you expecting that
that regulation would actually broaden
how many people will invest in in crypto
assets and then increase those prices
yes i do and that's the whole premise by
which i'm investing immunitable holdings
i think everything to do with the
internet whether it be a minor whether
it be circle whether it be immune
whether it be a wonderful another recent
investment of mine in decentralized
finance these are infrastructure place
for the long term now either you believe
in cryptocurrencies and you believe in
decentralized finance you believe in
what an nft is or you don't but if you
do then you have to make an allocation
decision and really what i'm hoping to
have happen is the regulator regulates
because they are i don't think the the
genie is out of the bottle now we're not
when you've got 30 plus billion dollars
worth of stable coin out there in just
one usdc name that's a huge indication
that there's institutional interest that
yet hasn't been
met demand and so the bottom line here
is this is software development the
whole thing is software development what
makes the country competitive is
technology which is primarily a
combination of firmware and software
development the regulator knows this we
want to lead the charge and decentralize
finance as a country we want to lead the
charge in deciding which of these
currencies and payment systems go
international we want to be the
developers and we want to maintain the
pace and the innovation and the
disruption we certainly don't want the
chinese doing that so it's a competitive
race
they've taken a shot with their own
currency which i mentioned i would never
own but at the same time the rest of the
world still uses
the us dollar as a settlement vehicle if
we can make a digital version of that in
usdc or something similar to it that
will become a standard globally the
regulator knows that and they will
continue to march towards regulating it
in my opinion
jordan kevin o'leary just talked about
how blockchain technology is really
software development
is it possible that this software
development blockchain becomes we find
one standard that just functions so well
that it ends up becoming a monopoly and
essentially replaces 99 of other
blockchains or do you see the market as
much more fragmented where certain
blockchains will be beneficial for
certain things and people might use uh
the ethereum network for one thing or
the cardano network for another thing
and who knows maybe bitcoin's future
network for something else
yeah so we're already seeing the
fragmentation happen solidity started as
the way to do smart contracts but if
we're being honest there's much better
more efficient ways to do smart
contracts solano's come up with better
ways to do it you can have a java
application run a smart contract which
is basically an atomic swap in a much
better way than even using solidity
which is very uh expensive and
burdensome to use as witnessed by the
fees uh that we're seeing on the on the
ethereum network
but what i think you'll end up having is
networks optimized for certain things so
have a network optimized just for nfts i
think you could have networks optimized
just for stable coins i think you'll
have networks optimized just for really
great governance and really great
appliance one of the reasons we built
hedera was to introduce really great
governance and compliance basically give
regulators a tool set to be able to bind
policy with a particular platform and a
jurisdiction the nodes on the hedera
network are run by google ibm boeing
deutsche telekom nomura unlike the
anonymous nodes and some of these other
networks which make regulators more
comfortable the nodes are in nemours
data center no more is a regulated
banking institution running a node on a
public blockchain network
and can enforce certain policies on
those nodes so i uh really where i think
this is going is you're going to have
networks optimized and specialized in
those areas now you may have multiple
nft networks but smart contracts and
nfts mostly nfts are smart contracts the
big common standard way of doing them is
erc 721 in the marketplace that's the
solidity standard that ethereum
introduced that's very burdensome on the
memory of a node on that particular
network and the more you have in ram or
in memory on those networks you
deprecate performance transactional
performance so it's going to be
difficult to be really great at micro
payments and really great at smart
contracts i think you're going to have
networks specializing but we'll
definitely have multiple networks there
will never be another bitcoin though
bitcoin is really our store of value
network and uh there it really is
digital gold uh i think you'll have a
general purpose application network like
a hedera and ethereum and avalanche and
solano there will be a few and i think
probably one or two win on the nft side
and the stable coin side that's
fascinating yeah i mean there's such a
public debate and and such uh loyalty
you could feel it it's almost like your
football team in terms of which
blockchain is going to win and do
everything but i like what you're saying
that we're probably going to see that
fragmentation continue uh now you hold
public companies do you hold any
robinhood they make some money off
crypto transactions
uh personally i uh i i don't publicly
disclose the the public equity plays or
investments that i make immutable
holdings is a structure where we're not
making balance sheet investments think
of us like a publicly traded venture
studio we like to make bets so for
example we acquired nft.com at the
beginning of this year and we decided
hey you know one it's got to be one of
the most highly sought after domain
names in the entire world right now i
literally field conversations and
inquiries on a daily basis to sell that
well we have built we have an incredible
engineering team these are former
facebook and google and stanford
engineers that have joined our team just
it's a tremendous effort behind building
what we think is going to be a really
amazing consumer product for collectors
and creators
and that's our specialty we're business
builders i built consumer software
brands that's where we're focusing in
terms of just making uh making bets
maybe we'll do a venture fund where we
we make early stage equity based
investments we haven't ruled out likely
that wouldn't be on a balance sheet that
probably be in our asset management
business at a certain point in time uh
but but for for us it's you know we're
we're the diversification play we're the
blockchain holding company the first uh
the first one to public markets
got it uh kevin o'leary do you hold any
alt coins directly or are you mostly
investing in funds for example like
immutable holdings
no immutable holdings i've invested in
as an infrastructure play through their
equity and inherent on in the value that
equity is what they have on their
balance sheet i i also own multiple
positions in various coins and tokens
and other chains and level one level
twos
uh what i've decided to do with this
situation i recently got involved um as
an investor and then a paid spokesperson
for ftx is i was looking for a platform
to manage all these assets on that i
could get my compliance department on
board for i described what i went
through just to get usdc on side with
circles infrastructure
i did the same thing with ftx and so at
some point in in the near future before
the end of the year what i don't want to
be accused of or ever be associated with
is this idea of promoting this uh you
know some some some coin that
is unknown and very thinly traded and
all that kind of thing i don't do that
i'm an investor i buy these positions
for long-term reasons
and
really don't rebalance outside of just
keeping the weightings under five
percent or whatever and so uh i've
decided to disclose my holdings um all
at once and say here's what i own i own
a lot of things now
and um
and and then just keep it transparent
because i don't like a lot of this
cowboy stuff that goes on in the crypto
space promoting this or that that you've
never heard of
um
that's that's not good for the long-term
stability of crypto it's fun almost
game-like in some nature and
and i'm not against it but but that's
day trading to me versus long-term uh
you know enhancement of productivity
again i look at all of it as software
i'm i invest i've came out of the
software industry i understand it i've
been involved in it my whole career life
but now i'm looking at it in terms of
enhancing productivity in all kinds of
different sectors and it is my stern
belief and it's a personal opinion and
the reason you would want to do this my
target is to get to seven percent of the
of of the operating companies holdings
in crypto
and in equities of cryptos by year end
but you would do this because you
believe at some point that the 12th
sector of the s p will become crypto and
decentralized finance i believe that
i you know i'm not saying it's going to
happen at any time soon but there's 11
sectors in the economy
including
real estate which was added recently and
i think crypto will make it there too so
you're investing or betting if you want
to put it that way that this will become
a new sector in our economy and it'll be
here forever
got it wow so no no shiba inu shout out
from kevin o'leary
but that's all right so um i we're
running out of time i want to ask both
of you i want to start with kevin
o'leary and then jordan uh i want to ask
both of you
about 45 to 60 percent of folks mention
that they invest in cryptocurrency as a
hedge
for inflation or against inflation
obviously inflation has been much more
persistent than it has been transitory
however there are some concerns that at
some point in the future we might head
towards low inflation or potentially
deflation if we go into a deflationary
environment
is there a risk to cryptocurrency prices
falling substantially jordan what's your
day
who i'm not a macro economist let me be
the first to disclose that what i see
happening now and you have to go back to
read the bitcoin white paper and
understand the commentary there's a
great book called the book of satoshi
where a group of people collected
literally all the comments of the people
that use the satoshi nakamoto handle and
the bitcoin talk forums um and uh and
and really just curated all of it
people were really upset during the 2008
financial crisis leading into all that
bank stimulus and all of those bailouts
bitcoin is absolutely reactionary to the
2008 financial crisis where people felt
disenfranchised that the bankers that
literally took us to the brink of a
financial armageddon were getting all of
this bailout money when people lost jobs
there were people committing suicide
just absolute tragedies being wiped out
financial institutions people losing
their entire life savings for honestly
reckless uh reckless decisions made by
the people managing
some of the biggest banks in the world
crypto came you have to understand that
crypto came from that these people call
themselves cyberpunks they're native a
lot of them operate anonymously on 4chan
and on reddit and as you mentioned uh
kevin kryptos tribal that's not that's
not going away because this is the
latest space race it's a modern space
race in a war of adoption uh and people
trying to become the de facto platforms
out there uh
it is well known and talked about in the
crypto ecosystem that 40 of all dollars
in circulation right now were printed in
the last 12 months people are monitoring
the us money supply and people are very
concerned very very concerned
people are voting with their dollars
right now they're deciding to take
stimulus money or to take the money that
they're making from the major
appreciation in their public equity
portfolios and to move it in things like
this new uh bito the pro shares bitcoin
etf people are betting 100 000 bitcoin
it's well talked about i believe that
we're going to see it either by the end
of this year and q1 of next year i i i i
won't speak for what i think will happen
in deflationary period again i don't see
myself as somebody who's qualified to
comment on that i look at the asset
class over a 10 20 30 year period where
i think we're going to continue to see
adoption here is with a growing mistrust
for institutions and people managing
central banks a growing mistrust among
the citizens of many different economies
i agree with kevin i don't think that
this digital remember this digital
chinese uh currency is gonna gain
adoption uh what people want in a
central bank digital currency is
transparency into the money supply they
want scarcity that's why people are
buying bitcoin that's why people buy hr
that's why people buy salon on ethereum
and all these coins they're scarce
whereas dollars can be recklessly
printed shares by the way tesla stock
elon can capitalize and issue new tesla
stock and by the way gold and silver
they can always find more gold and
silver so when you look at cash more can
be printed when you look at gold and
silver more can be discovered when you
look at um when you look at you know
again shares just you can obviously
dilute a cap table uh you cannot do that
in digital assets you cannot do that in
cryptocurrency at least for most of them
and that is the tremendous property that
people are demanding
that's where the demand for this is
coming from so um i i i can only see
this growing from here
well yeah i mean it's it's very
interesting i mean you're right i mean
we printed 40 percent uh upwards of 40
percent of all the currency that's in
circulation now uh our velocity of money
has plummeted the amount of times people
are circulating money because maybe
they're saving or investing more but it
makes you wonder call lee if people
rotated back to the amount of spending
we had back in 2019 velocity money pop
back up we'd see inflation off the
charts it'd be incredible uh kevin
o'leary your thoughts uh and i know
we've talked about it before but i want
to hear your updated thoughts and now
that we've got the taper coming this
inflation's lasting longer
or do we care if we see inflation
continuing a deflationary environment
any risk to crypto or are we going to a
million over the next 10 to 20 years
here
i think the value of of bitcoin will
continue to increase over time and maybe
we'll beat the indices the traditional
equity and fixed income indices and
that's why you should if you consider
that have some allocation to it which
would not be a bad idea and i don't
think you have to put ever you know bet
the farm and only owned bitcoin you can
own a lot of different coins tokens and
infrastructure equities as we talked
about
but you know having no allocation to it
at all in a portfolio an operating
company like mine is to say that you
don't believe in any of it and i'm
simply not that person anymore i was
very skeptical at the beginning but as
things changed and the regulators
changed and became more open to it so
did i and i think regarding the
inflation debate
there's a huge you know discussion going
on with money managers globally as to
whether this is transitory inflation
caused by broken supply chains for
example if you're building a car in
america and you used to get all of your
parts from asia and now 30 percent of
them are no longer available or stuck on
a ship outside of
outside of the lax airport or
you know outside of the port in los
angeles which is a horrific situation
you're going to source those same nuts
and bolts stateside at a 30 increase in
cost and that's part of what we're
seeing in the inflation run but if
that's true and we fix the supply chain
which we're hoping we're going to be
doing over the next 24 months
that will be you know transitory however
not everybody agrees with that scenario
and that's why the debate is ensuing and
maybe that's one of the reasons you're
seeing this new fresh highs or close to
it on bitcoin and some of the other uh
digital assets starting to move as well
you you really don't know because
bitcoin has not yet proven itself to be
an alternative asset class or counter
cyclical asset class to a correcting
market if the market were to go down 5
000 points tomorrow you would probably
see a correction of bitcoin as well so
it hasn't made that transition yet
whether it will in the future isn't
unknown but to have zero allocation to
it
seems um
you know a bad idea i think you need you
have to decide what your risk tolerance
is and your your tolerance for
volatility itself and then make your
decision what you're going to own and
i've done that and my target i've
disclosed will be seven percent of the
year and it could go to 20 in the years
ahead we'll see what happens
that's incredible that's an incredible
evolution and thank you for having a
flexible mindset uh and uh it's
fascinating to see you increasing your
allocation uh one very quick follow-up
and then i want to ask your final
thoughts kevin o'leary last time we
spoke you said you were somewhere around
30 cash have you allocated more to
crypto now since we last spoke or
where's your cash going
no my cash remains very very high
because we've also changed our
allocation
between equities and fixed income from
50 50 to 70 30. so we had to sell a lot
of fixed income assets
i'm working hard to deploy this cash i
mean
when you're deploying um
you know a significant position like
that you don't do it overnight you weigh
it into the market in different asset
classes you
it's primarily driven by the very large
sale i made in commercial real estate
over an 18-month period down from 31
percent of the of the holding company to
eight and so
we spent decades building that portfolio
cap rates got too low for my comfort and
i decided to sell the majority of it and
so it's going to take me a while to
deploy this capital in the meantime i'm
very frustrated with the cash desks that
i use and i use them all over the world
offering me 21 22 23 24 basis points
on an annual basis which is why i've
gotten involved in usdc and continue to
work with the circle people to develop
that platform to be compliant for my
needs
for clarity for folks watching that is
less than one quarter of one percent of
a yield on kevin o'leary's cash and that
is very frustrating uh jordan i want to
hear final thoughts from you uh
cryptocurrency uh hundred thousand you
know bitcoin hundred thousand bitcoin a
million i wanna hear a little bit more
about how people can invest in you
ticker symbol company tell me more about
that we'll go to kevin o'leary for his
final thoughts and then we're off
uh for again thanks for having me uh
kevin uh it's been a fantastic
conversation uh i i
we're immutable holdings you can go to
immutableholdings.com our ticker symbols
hold this is not financial advice do
your own research what we're merely
saying is that uh beyond just owning
cryptocurrency having equity exposure to
whether it's the bitcoin miners whether
it's voyager or galaxy or hut as kind of
mentioned on the show do your research
speak with a financial advisor there are
equity exposure plays for you to take
indirect exposure to the sector i do
agree with kevin
uh uh o'leary that i do think that we're
looking at what is going to become the
12th sector on the s p i do think we'll
see trillion dollar blockchain
businesses at some point in the future
if you look at where coinbase is uh
they're only at 20 x from where they are
right now and when you look at 68
million global users on a platform like
coinbase ftx uh that kevin is now
o'leary is now involved in here in the
united states getting their compliance
uh licenses in place growing their team
uh sponsoring things like the miami heat
stadium i really think that you're gonna
see a tremendous growth in this
particular sector sure there will be
market cycles bitcoin corrections ups
and downs but companies like ftse
coinbase make money when crypto prices
go up and down they make their money in
volatility so we're really excited about
that
um and uh you can follow us on social
and uh yeah i think i think bitcoin's
gonna go to the moon and i'm excited to
just be along for the ride what what's
your social
uh jordan freed is the best place to
follow me on twitter i tweet about the
market immutable holdings h bar all the
above
okay awesome yeah that's actually very
interesting coinbase is a 68 billion
dollar market cap right now tesla just
crossed a one trillion dollar market cap
uh and uh and you're thinking we're
gonna see uh basically cryptocurrency
companies
the size of tesla very very bullish
that's incredible kevin and
and not to interrupt you if you guys
remember palm pilots i just saw this
article literally 20 years ago palm
pilot the company behind the palm pilot
was valued at more than apple in google
combined so when you look at where uh
when you look at where we've gone like
no one uses pawn pilot anymore think
about 20 years from now i think it's out
of the realm of possibility that
coinbase could be as valuable if not
more so
wow kevin o'leary final thoughts
cryptocurrency to the moon i think the
key to getting involved in it regardless
of your age and what demographic you're
in is education
um i feel the same way about investing
there are certain principles of
diversification
that you should always adhere to
regardless of what asset class or what
sector the economy that you play in
uh and the same for crypto so we've
discussed many different ways during
this conversation to to be involved from
the equities of companies that mine
bitcoin to those that are building
infrastructure like uh immutable
holdings uh that that is another way to
do it um wonderful is another one
there's lots of different companies that
are they're involved in in this but it's
really about educating yourself and and
not and and
getting diversification your portfolio
it's not just about bitcoin and ethereum
anymore it just isn't there's just too
much
other software being developed that has
tremendous productivity potential and i
think exposure to that makes sense if
you like that video wait did you see my
next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe